Okay.
Let's get right into a audience.
Questions for the week.
There are some good ones.
A first one.
Hey David, did you see Bob Lasar on Joe Rogan?
Are His claims about UFOs credible?
Do you believe him?
I did see this and I watched this with great
interests.
So if you're not familiar with this, there's
a guy named Bob Lasar who was on Joe Rogan's
program a week or two ago and Bobolis our
is now about 60 years old.
And he says he's a physicist that he worked
on extra terrestrial technology including
flying saucers.
He worked trying to reverse engineer this,
uh, supposedly alien technology at a place
in your, uh, called [inaudible] near the area,
51 location in the United States southwest.
And not only was he on Joe Rogan recently,
there's a Netflix documentary about him now.
Uh, and I watched the documentary and I watched
the interview on Joe Rogan and what's stunning
and interesting about this particular guy
compared to some other UFO, uh, people making
claims about UFOs and extraterrestrial technology
is that he is so easily able to talk about
what seemed like such specific details that
would be really difficult to make up.
Like if he didn't really do this stuff, if
he didn't really see this stuff, it would
be hard for him to so articulately and specifically
and consistently talk about this material.
He says very clearly what he does remember
and things that he doesn't remember him.
Sometimes people say, you know, if he was
just making it up he would always have answers
or it would seem more difficult for him to
recall.
Suppose it details.
He was really specific about where was he
and wasn't he allowed into when he was working
at this.
He explains in great detail how gravity fields
and element one 15 and all sorts of things
work.
And I admit it's interesting and it's compelling
to watch him talk about it in the documentary
and with Joe Rogan.
But I got a ton of people asking me, do I
believe the substance of what he says because
he seems so convincing.
And if it's true, then the government has
been carrying out this massive cover up operation
about the fact that we have alien spacecraft
and technologies that are not of this world,
which would be a massive, massive revelation
and a scandal and cited as a sort of defense
of a lot of the things that Bobolis are talked
about more generally in terms of technology.
Uh, include things that he talked about, which
have since become realities or, or, or have
been sort of, he's been vindicated hand scanners,
elements of wave theory have been proven true
over the years.
And in the documentary he also says that he
was raided by the FBI while the documentary
itself was in production.
Um, which would again suggest that there is
a government effort to cover up his ability
to tell the story, the story, the truth about
what he's been involved in.
Now it's important to recognize that there's
no actual evidence or paperwork or video or
anything that confirms law enforcement was
at his place or rated him.
I mean, nothing is presented and I think that's
an important starting point for our conversation.
So in the end, I don't believe the specifics
of what Bob Alizar is saying and I want to
be clear, I'm not saying that we are alone
in the universe.
I don't know that to be true mathematically.
There's a very compelling case for there being
alien life elsewhere in the universe.
That's not what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is that the Bob Lasar claims
for me have very quickly become sort of these
conspiracy conspiracy things where absence
of evidence is interpreted as actual evidence.
So as an example, there's no evidence of the
FBI raid that he claims happened.
This is seen by those who believe Bobolis
are that clearly the raid happened and was
covered up and all evidence of it was removed.
Occam's razor would suggest that he simply
made it up.
The simplest explanation for why there is
no evidence for that rate is that it didn't
happen.
Along the same lines, there's no evidence
that Bob Lasar went to school at the places
he claims he went to school.
The documentary and the Rogan interview suggest
that he did get these degrees from the places
he claims, but in order to discredit him,
there's been a campaign to erase all evidence
of him having attended those schools, transcripts
and admissions records were deleted.
People who attended the schools at the time,
he claims to be there have been gotten to,
and that's why they're saying they have no
recollection of bubbles are going there.
It's a cover up to hide the fact that he's
really educated in physics.
Again, outcomes razor suggests that the simplest
explanation is the best one, which is he simply
made it up.
There was no record of him having attended
those schools because he didn't.
When you go further and you look into Bobolis,
ars claims about gravity and whatever else,
there are plenty of actual, uh, people we
know to be physicists who debunked the stuff
that he says.
Now I can't possibly debunk every scientific
claim.
Bible is our makes nor would it be relevant
because people who believe it would just come
up with new explanations as to why he, he's
believable, but as an example, Lasar claims
that one of his vindications is that science
has now determined gravity to be a wave, which
he's been saying for a long time and a lot
of the stuff he says about the alien propulsion
systems depend on that actual physicist just
don't agree with that premise.
They say there is one theory about gravity,
general relativity, which says gravity is
neither a particle nor a wave.
Um, there are things called gravitational
waves, but actual physicists widely say that
even the way that Bob Lasar was setting up
the conversation about gravity is wrong.
But when you watch it, it seems so compelling
and he seems so articulate about this stuff
that people do get pulled in.
So long story short, without diagnosing anyone.
I've spoken to my dad about this extensively.
Who's a mental health professional and generally
about the, not about Bible as are specifically,
but I've spoken to him generally about these
folks who sound so smart and they seem so
grounded, uh, and yet they talk about these
wild topics but seems so normal without anything
else unusual going on with them.
You talk to them about sports or politics
or whatever and they just seem with it.
Why is it that they wouldn't be believable
about this one area, whether it's aliens or
whatever else?
There's a condition called paraphenia.
Okay.
That might apply to some of these folks.
I'm not even pretending to diagnose bibles
are, I'm merely telling you there is a condition
that explains this and Paraphenia is a condition
which is characterized by a very organized
system of delusions that sometimes include
paranoia.
Sometimes there are hallucinations, often
auditory and sometimes there are not, so you
don't even need to believe or argue about
whether the person believes the things they
say themselves or they're just making it up.
Para phrenia notably doesn't come with that
deteriorating intellect or the personality
issues that lots of schizophrenia people do
experience.
When schizophrenia people get serious schizophrenia,
um, they often start to behave in ways that
generally don't make sense.
You meet them, you can't have a conversation
with them about sports or politics or whatever.
Their entire intellect and personality become
compromised.
With Para phrenia you will much more commonly
have people who don't act strangely or hold
bizarre out of this world for lack of a better
term beliefs except for this one area and
one thing that is often a part of Para Frania
is the belief of being persecuted.
That paranoia also is, is often common in
schizophrenia, which is right there in Baba
is our story, right?
He claims to have been rated for the FBI.
There's no evidence that that raid took place.
He believes he's being surveilled.
He won't talk about element one 15 within
earshot of phones that have the battery in
them because he believes that it's possible
that he is being surveilled there.
So to be clear, I'm not saying Bobolis are
his pair of phrenic.
What I'm telling you is that there are simpler
explanations for these things, which sometimes
should be considered, and I don't find Bible
as our story particularly compelling.
Tell me where I'm wrong.